FIGHTING FOR HIS LIFE AFTER A
WILD POLICE PURSUIT REVIVE
WITH AN UPDATE ON HIS
WELCOME BACK TO BACK TO
SCHOOL IS AN EXCITING BUT
EXPENSIVE TIME SO CHANNEL 8
TEAMED UP WITH SMITH TO DONATE
SCHOOL SUPPLIES TO TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS IN NEED SO LET'S
OF THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
FOUNDATION TO TELL US MORE
ABOUT HOW THE DRIVE IS HELPING
OUR COMMUNITY WELCOME. THANK
YOU SO TO DRIVE STARTED ON
JULY 19TH AND IT'S GOING TILL
TODAY TODAY IS THE LAST DAY TO
DONATE AT YOUR LOCAL SMITH
STORE SO HOW TO GO WHAT DOES
IT MEAN TO YOU GUYS WHAT WE'RE
HEARING A LOT OF ENTHUSIASM
FROM THE STORE MANAGERS THAT
WERE WORKING WITH ITS MESS FOR
SO APPRECIATIVE OF THE STRIVE
YOU KNOW IT'S A DIFFERENT BACK
TO SCHOOL SEASON MIGHT NEED
TIME YES, AND SO EVERYBODY HAS
BEEN CHIPPING IN AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE
THAT WHAT'S THE
AFTER YOU GO IN YOU DONATE
YOUR SUPPLIES WHERE THEY GO
AFTER TODAY, SO THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION FOUNDATION ACTUALLY
HAS A GIANT TEACHER WAREHOUSE
CALLED THE TEACHER EXCHANGE
COUNTY CAN COME AND SHOP AT
OUR WAREHOUSE FOR A SMALL
MEMBERSHIP FEE THEY CAN GET UP
TO $500 WORTH OF SUPPLIES
THAT'S GREAT THAT'S GREAT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE FORGET
ABOUT THE TEACHER SOMETIMES
THE STUDENTS OBVIOUSLY WE NEED
TO HELP THEM, BUT THE TEACHERS
NEEDED AS WELL SO OBVIOUSLY
LIKE YOU MENTIONED A UNIQUE
TIME FOR STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS.
WHAT ARE YOU ALL EXPECTING
FROM THE DRIVE IN YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT PRODUCTS SO WHAT
WHAT'S IN DEMAND. MOSTLY WELL
SINCE WE'RE BACK IN
CLASSROOMS. IT'S ALL THE
REGULAR SCHOOL BUT TEACHERS
ARE TELLING US THAT THEY NEED
WHAT THEY THEIR FAMILIES CAN'T
AFFORD TO BRING TO ALL AND SO
THE MORE SUPPLIES WE CAN
PROVIDE THEM THE BETTER ON THE
AVERAGE TEACHER SPENDS MORE
THAN $400 A YEAR HOW OWN MONEY
ON THEIR OWN POCKET, YES, JUST
FOR THEIR STUDENT, YES
EVERYTHING THEY NEED YEAH AND
AND CONSIDERING THE TIME
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE SOME LYSOL
WIPES LOT OF HAND SANITIZER
WILL BE IN NEED AND STUDENTS
CAN'T REALLY SHARE SUPPLIES
RIGHT SO YOU NEED MORE THIS
YEAR WE ARE HEARING THAT FROM
TEACHING YEAH THAT THEY
THEY'RE NOT TRYING HIS MAIN
CRAYONS PENCILS I MEAN SO
THINK ABOUT ALL OF THAT IF YOU
HAVE 30 YOUR CLASSROOM, YOU'RE
BUYING THAT MANY MORE SUPPLIES
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S SO
SUPPORTED US AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT ABSOLUTELY WAS
SPEAKING OF THAT HOW CAN WE
SUPPORT THE FURTHER BEYOND THE
SCHOOL SUPPLY DRIVE. WHILE THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION A LOSS FOR
TO THE TEACHER EXCHANGE YOU
CAN GO TO THE P E F DOT ORG.
AND YOU CAN SPONSOR YOUR OWN
CHILD'S TEACHER YOU CAN
SPONSOR ANY OTHER RANDOM
TEACHER AND IT'S JUST A REALLY
WAY GREAT WAY TO SHOW TEACHER
SUPPORT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT'S
AND IT WAS A HARD SCHOOL YEAR
LAST YEAR IT WAS OK WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH KIRSTEN FOR ALL
YOU DO THANK YOU DISMISS FOOD
AND DRUG FOR SPONSORING THE
SEGMENT YOU CAN DONATE SCHOOL
LOCATION, THE DEADLINE FOR TO
FOR DONATIONS IS TODAY LIKE WE
MENTIONED ALL SUPPLIES DONATED A
WILL BENEFIT THE NDEZ))
PUBLIC
EDUCATION FOUNDATION'S TEACHER
EXCHANGE PROGRAM TO SEE OFF